it's the holidays love is Emir and your
fellow beauty mogul miss Kylie Jenner
she's instagramming pictures with her
and Travis Scott in a ring we're just
asking you are they they call each other
husband a wife are they married
a gaged what is the situation you know
I'm literally need to ask her that is
gonna be my next question on our group
chat we were chatting on the way over
here and I think we just saw think like
that's like you know what they call each
other but I have no idea and just like
you guys I'll find out I don't know if
I'll share the news with you guys but I
will I'll have to ask myself all right
last question just being here in the
k'kaw beauty shop how does it make you
feel in a couple words emotional
overwhelmed proud definitely proud of my
team because everyone worked so hard if
anyone you know says that you know it's
one person doing it on their own they be
lying I'm so proud of the design team
everyone from start to finish on this so
just proud is my main word